die kollegen klingen bitte nehmen sie
platz
dies eröffnet für die heutige 121 122
sitzung konnte zwischen den fraktionen
keine tagesordnung vereinbart werden
fraktion der fdp hat den vorschlag der
anderen fraktionen widersprochen
ich habe den bundestag mit der frau
geschlagen tagesordnung einberufen
nach § 21 absatz 3 unserer
geschäftsordnung ist für die genehmigung
der tagesordnung ein blinder beschluss
erforderlich
die koalitionsfraktion beantragen die
vorgeschlagenen tagesordnung um die um
der zusatzpunkte liste aufgeführten
punkte zu erweitern und der frist für
den beginn der beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden
die tagesordnungspunkte 6 b 16 und 18
sollen abgesetzt werden
der tagesordnungspunkt 15 soll ebenfalls
abgesetzt und ja der anlage auf der
drucksache 14 1343 mit dem titel
fachlich fundierte und europäisch
einheitliche rahmenbedingungen für eine
wettbewerbsfähige landwirtschaft mit
zukunft im umfang von 38 minuten
debattiert werden
des weiteren soll auch der
tagesordnungspunkt 20 abgesetzt
und es hat dessen der antrag auf der
drucksache 14 1382 mit dem titel 30
jahre grünes band männern debatten zeit
von 38 minuten aufgerufen werden
darüber hinaus kommen dazu den in der
zusatzpunkt gewichte dargestellten
änderungen des ablaufs und schließlich
mache ich noch auf eine nachträgliche
ausschuss überweisung im anhang zur
zusatzpunkte mische aufmerksam
außerdem war die fraktion der afg frisch
gerecht beantragt auf die heutige
tagesordnung die wahl eine
stellvertreter des präsidenten des
deutschen bundestages einem zweiten
wahlgang aufzusetzen und diesen punkt
nach den debatten punkten aufzurufen
wer hat das wort zur geschäftsordnung
gefühls herr kollege bommel
die hand das wort
herr präsident meine damen und herren
mit neuen tricks wollen die alten
parteien hier im haus verhindern dass
die afd
die größere opposition im präsidium des
bundestages vertreten ist
dabei fordert die geschäftsordnung das
ausdrücklich wörtlich steht da jede
fraktion des deutschen bundestages ist
durch mindestens einen vize-präsidenten
im präsidium vertreten wörtlich denn
diese features an große macht deshalb
dürfen alle fraktionen einstellen nur
die afd wird von den anderen blockiert
alle anderen fraktionen haben ihre
kandidaten gegenseitig gewählt aber
unsere kandidaten immer durchfallen
lassen seit zwei langen jahren heute
gehen sie noch einen schritt weiter sie
wollen noch nicht mal mehr wahlen
zulassen auf die tagesordnung setzen
meine damen und herren dass wir hier
erleben ist eine neue dimension des
kalten machtmissbrauchs eine
unterdrückung der größten opposition
durch die linksgrünen mainstream
parteien hier im haus bis tief in die
cdu hinein
das ist so dramatisch weil auch die afd
dringend einen vize-präsidenten braucht
denn der hat große macht er kann zum
beispiel in redeschlachten jedem das
wort entziehen
er kann strafen verhängen er kann sogar
bestimmen ob das parlament
beschlussfähig ist oder nicht
ein beispiel ende juni saßen hier
spätabends 91 abgeordnete von über 700
die regierung wollte trotzdem wichtige
gesetze zum datenschutz verabschieden
dazu musste aber eine mehrheit der
abgeordneten da seien mindestens 355 die
waren aber nicht da
was macht ihr die amtierende vize
präsidentin
sie weigerte sich einfach die
beschlussfähigkeit zu überprüfen
und behauptete wahrheitswidrig die
mehrheit sei da meine damen und herren
bundestags videos zeigen eindeutig dass
dies nicht der fall war nur 91 waren da
nicht 355 so wurde ein wichtiges gesetz
rechtswidrig hier durchgepeitscht nur
die afg protestierte die vertreter der
alten parteien die präsidium deckten
sich gegenseitig sie sind ja unter sich
wir haben ja kein vize meine damen und
herren so kann es nicht bleiben hier
muss sich dringend etwas ändern im sinne
des parlamentarismus
aber diese änderung die blockieren sie
ja seien sie doch ehrlich wir könnten
doch barack obama oder kreta thunberg
oder den dalai lama aufstellen sie
würden sie nicht wählen obwohl uns nach
recht gesetz und verfassung ein vize
zusteht ich kann ihnen nur sagen ich
[Applaus]
kann ihnen nur sagen beschweren sie sich
nicht über viktor orban oder die ungarn
sie gehen gegen die demokratisch
gewählte opposition die oft schlimmer
vor als ist jene vorwerfen ihrem haus
und sie haben ja selbst eine claudia
roth zur vizepräsidentin gewählt die
jüngst öffentlich mit israel hasser mit
juden feinen sich getroffen hat videos
zeigen wie sie einen hochrangigen
iranischen politiker mit ausgestreckten
abend herzlich begrüßt der immer wieder
die vernichtung israels fordert sind den
holocaust leugnet die größte deutsche
tageszeitung titelte eine schande für
den bundestag zu recht meine damen und
herren
was für eine abgrundtiefe heuchelei in
diesem haus sie messen mit zweierlei maß
und sie alle hier machen mit das muss
ich mal festgehalten werden
zurück zur geschäftsordnung mit einem
trick mit einem trick wollen sie uns auf
eine drei wochen mindestregeln zurück
zwingen die hier im parlament sonst nie
angewendet wird die innerhalb die nie
angewendet wird nicht bei
parlamentarischen initiativen und schon
gar nicht bei wahlen nie angewendet
schauen sie die heutige tagesordnung an
nichts von einer solchen frist schauen
sich die tagesordnung aller bisherigen
sitzungen an nichts von solcher vrees
die zwei jahren nicht vor allem ihre
eigenen vize präsidenten haben sie mit
einer 4 günstigeren frist gewährt die
sie aufgesetzt haben als sie die frist
der afg heute aufzwingen wollen das ist
politische willkür schlimmsten ausmaßes
in diesem haus meine damen und herren
und es ist ein schlag ins gesicht jener
sechs millionen menschen die uns gewählt
haben zur größten und wichtigsten
opposition in diesem haus diese menschen
haben ein recht darauf dass ihre stimmen
im bundestag gleichberechtigt zur
geltung kommen die alle anderen auch und
genau das wollen sie verhindern aber
freuen sie sich nicht zu früh herr
kollege baumann nach § 29 absatz 3
absatz 4 darf zur geschäftsordnung der
einzelnen redner nicht länger als fünf
minuten sprechen die fünf minuten sind
abgelaufen
wie kommen sie zu ende freuen sie sich
nicht so früh die wahlen in sachsen und
brandenburg haben das schon gezeigt und
am nächsten sonntag die türen kriegen
sie dafür die nächste krise
[Applaus]
gibt es weitere wortmeldungen zur
geschäftsordnung herr kollege buschmann
herr präsident meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen
liebe gäste liebe zuschauer der deutsche
bundestag hat gestern eine debatte zur
meinungsfreiheit geführt und zur
meinungsfreiheit gehört dass man sich
jede meinung anhört dass jeder alles
sagen kann dass man ihm zuhört selbst
wenn es der größte blödsinn ist dass man
dann aber auch den widerspruch ertragen
muss wir zeigen dass heute den blödsinn
haben wir jetzt gehört jetzt kommt der
widerspruch herr kollege baumann mit
krokodilstränen verkünden sie hier sie
hätten was mit demokratie am hut warum
widersprechen sie denn der tagesordnung
sie widersprechen der tagesordnung weil
sie sich andere debatten aus als andere
debatten slots wünschen ich will noch
einmal den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
erklären was die afg unter demokratie
versteht die ard will das bewährte
schema dass die opposition in anlehnung
an das wahlergebnis hier in kernzeiten
reden kann umdrehen die afg stellt gut
ein viertel der oppositions stimmen will
aber die hälfte der kernzeit slots haben
wie kann man mehr das wählervotum
ignorieren und missachten als mit einem
solchen vorschlag
die afg vergisst krokodilstränen
angeblich zugunsten der demokratie und
will gerade tatsächlich die
bundesrepublik deutschland mit der
demokratischen partei von viktor orban
und der arbeit von viktor orban
vergleichen mit wem dennoch demnächst
mit venezuela sie haben sämtliche
maßstäbe verloren herr baumann und das
hat nichts mit dem schutz der demokratie
zu tun
und schließlich herr baumann sie sagen
sie würden ach so unfair behandelt
werden wir sein gemeine menschen hier
weil wir auf die einhaltung der
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages bestehen und deshalb erkläre
ich ihnen den sinn und den zweck dieser
regelung ihre fraktion hat mit ansage
angekündigt dass sie ein attentat auf
die integrität und die arbeitsfähigkeit
dieses parlaments vorhat auf papier hat
ihre fraktion geschrieben dass sie
diesen deutschen bundestag mit
wahlgängen solange fluten wollen bis wir
hier nicht mehr arbeitsfähig sind die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung hat
dieses strategiepapier bekommen und fast
ist zusammen dass diese flutung des
parlaments mit wahlgängen dazu dienen
soll die arbeit ich zitiere des
bundestags ist systematisch zu behindern
und das würde so steht es wörtlich in
ihrem papier drin das ansehen des
bundestages nachhaltig beschädigen und
das vertrauen in unsere demokratie
erschüttern und das ist es was sie
wollen
und dass wir in ansehung dieses
attentats mit ankündigung auf die
rechtlichen regelungen der
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages bestehen das hat mit recht
und ordnung und mit demokratie und mit
anstand zu tun und da lassen wir uns
nicht ins bockshorn jagen ihnen geht es
weder um demokratie
ihnen geht es ja nicht mal um ihren
kandidaten als vizepräsidentin geht es
nur um eins und das hat herr baumann
hier gezeigt sie wollen hier eine
apfelsine kiste aufstellen mit der sie
wahlkampfparolen verkünden können aber
dafür ist die geschäftsordnungsdebatte
des deutschen bundestags nicht da und
auch da haben sie gezeigt dass sie gar
nicht wissen worum es hier geht und
deshalb lehnen wir eher attentat mit
ansage ab
abgeordneter und stolz die haben eben
den kollegen muss man als terroristen
bezeichnet ich rufe sie zur ordnung
jetzt frage ich ob weiteres wort und
geschäftsordnung gewünscht wird
das ist nicht der fall dann kommen wir
jetzt abstimmung über den aufsätzen
antrag der fraktion der afd wahl eines
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestag
das muss ganz schnell erklären was
bringt war es der vorsitzende der
unions-fraktion sagt gerade wenn es so
ist was beatrix von storch gesagt hat
dann ist eine ermahnung wie sie wolfgang
schäuble gerade ausgesprochen hat zu
wenig bringen sie mich nicht in die
versuchung ihnen auch in ordnungsrufe
erteilen zu müssen ich bin mitten dabei
über die abstimmung außerdem dürfen
können sie entscheidungen des
amtierenden sitzung gleichen präsidenten
im ältestenrat rügen aber wird nicht im
plenum mit dieser belehrung lasse ich es
jetzt bewenden aber jetzt aber sehen wir
bei der abstimmung über den
aussetzungsantrag der fraktionen der afd
wahl eines vizepräsident des deutschen
bundestags im zweiten wahlgang
das stimmt für diesen aussetzungsantrag
das ist die wehr stimmt dagegen wer
enthält sich dann ist der antrag mit den
stimmen der afg gegen die stimmen des
oedter der übrigen fraktionen abgelehnt
und damit
[Musik]
damit liegen damit kommen wir zur
feststellung der tagesordnung der
heutigen 21 und der morgigen 122 sitzung
mit den genannten in der fraktion l
vereinbarten ergänzungen
wer stimmt für diese tagesordnung so
breite mehrheit für die im vorfeld
besprochen eine tagesordnung
beispielsweise im ältestenrat des
bundestages und vielleicht noch mal für
alle hieß vorhin verpasst haben wolfgang
schäuble der bundestagspräsident hat
gerückt wo hin dass beatrix von storch
aus den reihen der fw fraktion marco
buschmann einen terroristen genannt hat
nachdem der nun wiederum sehr heftig den
regen geschäftsordnungs beitrag von
bernd baumann dem ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
fdp fraktion oder gerügt und kritisiert
hatte aber terrorist ist halt kein
sprachgebrauch der hier im bundestag
zugelassen wird
daraufhin hatte das brinkhaus gefordert
dass das stärker zum üben sei durch den
bundestagspräsidenten der wiederum das
haben sie dann wahrscheinlich mit
gekommen hat gesagt dass er das nun gar
nicht so gerne mag das sind wir
sitzungspräsident auch für entsprechende
weise angesprochen wird sondern dass da
nun wiederum der das
der ältestenrat zuständig